this episode brought to you by
stamps.com why go to the store to get
stamps when you can have them printed
right at home for your convenience
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it
[Music]
there I did a nice little Christmas
intro and nobody got hurt no world's
blew up or anything everything is good I
don't hear that I don't hear that either
whatever it is I am sure it had nothing
to do with my Christmas and truth anyway
let's talk about live shows since pretty
much the dawn of television live shows
has been a very regular thing they've
had a bit of an explosion these past
five years shows like The Sound of Music
with Carrie Underwood Peter Pan with
Christopher Walken and The Wiz with
Queen Latifah at the raking in big
numbers for NBC clearly because they
were good right oh yeah poor kids is a
kind of good not wanting to be left out
of the musical equivalent of dogs
playing poker Fox decided to throw their
head into the ring with grease live with
Vanessa Hudgens and the Rocky Horror
Picture Show with Laverne Cox the
specials apparently did well enough to
warn what Fox was hoping to be the
crowning achievement of Polk eNOS
because lord knows we haven't made it
hokey enough already
a Christmas storm
in America's need to destroy this movie
a Christmas story live does its best to
turn that small-town innocent family
classic with a hint of an edge into a
tacky singing Hallmark card covered in
falling glitter with an unfunny joke
inside but where card only gives you a
second of annoyance this one delivers
two hours and 15 minutes of cyanide
fruitcake and that's without commercials
with commercials eight free goddamn
hours the special is like a forgettable
ugly sweater that someone paid millions
of dollars to glamor out creating an
even more forgettable ugly sweater it's
the kind of special that rips out what
was charming and fresh from the original
and replaces it with what Google
translates would interpret as charming
and fresh it's a miserable experience
from beginning to end so let's look it
over from beginning to end
this is why Christmas can't have nice
things let's take a look at Christmas
story live I'll try this again let's
take a look at Christmas story live
okay my bad I seem to put on Old Navy
presents a Camp Rock Christmas what's
that ah the fictional person I'm
pretending is off camera to make this
joke work is telling me this is in fact
a Christmas story don't know how I
didn't recognize that I mean Christ
literally the first scene is 100% wrong
it took effort to be this wrong it's
like starting off a Christmas classic
everybody knows like this well now I
feel obligated to say this don't do that
Fox we actually know you would now so
after trying to make Ralphie's bunny
pajamas somehow hot we bizarrely have
enough sexy rabbits thank you something
kind of resembling a Christmas story
finally starts and at first I will admit
it is impressive to think this is all
done live the shots the visuals the
movement the timing this would all be
difficult to do on its own taking out
that you have to get it done on the
first take but sadly it's narrated by an
actor who's known for giving a
performance like it's his first take
Matthew he was good in that one thing
Broderick Broderick's entire performance
is the most constant reminder that this
is live because he's so incredibly
awkward that you swear rather than
creating a motion first and racing
against the clock second he's racing
against the clock first and creating a
motion never I hadn't renewed reasons
for optimism Santa was on the case I'd
heard a lot of know in the past three
weeks from no less than Santa himself
like Michigan was so polluted you could
run halfway to Milwaukee before you sank
to the bottom here it is there it is the
house on Cleveland Street ah Higbee's
the high-water mark of the pre-christmas
season everything he says it's like the
flower shop scene from the room any
human feeling accidentally entering the
equation is clearly an indirect
by-product for months I'd been thinking
of the Red Rider and nothing else now
here it was the real thing that's a lot
of Maya Rudolph plays Ralphie's mom
and Ralphie is played by Andy Walken no
relation to Christopher Walken that I
know of yet somehow he still inherited
every one of his scary faces
desperate okay before I go too harsh on
this kid she is a kid and he's still
learning and to his credit he's been in
a lot of other stuff movies a steady gig
on a TV show I legitimately hope his
talent grows and he has a nice long
career but when you put that kid in I
warping glasses with frame so black even
Tim Burton would say too dark on a live
show where you can't always get the best
lighting flattering camera angles and
you're encouraged to come across big and
silly unchecked that kid can be
terrifying look at the way the shadow
hits his eyes he looks like Harry Potter
turning into Gollum did you know the
same director of a Christmas story also
directed black Christmas you would if he
put these shots of that kid in both of
them okay well let's hope his singing
can balance things out he's really good
and the kids are alright anyway he's
just a little boy what's projects excuse
that's right boys take it from me me if
you want to keep your homestead free of
villains I give you mmm oh one of these
days the Blue Fairy will come and make
me a real actor there's nothing wrong
with your monitor by the way the aspect
ratio keeps changing I'm assuming this
is whenever there's a fantasy Ralphie is
having which means there must have been
some confusing thoughts he was going
through when these women came out in his
pj's
okay look kid I really hope one day you
can look back and be like remember
Christmas story live wasn't that funny
how much that didn't work and I didn't
belong there but now I'm a huge star
making millions and everybody who loves
me haha I can look back and laugh now
it's funny ha ha ha for right now
the special is interrupted by a nice
recognition of the first responders to
last year's California wildfires please
join us in honoring the first responders
who put their lives on the line to serve
and protect us all but Allen it it's a
little muddied we're immediately after
instead of promoting a wildfire charity
you could give to it instead pushes a
special Twitter emoji if you tweet their
hashtag don't heck with those wildfires
I want that emoji I deserve that
if you seen the original a lot of this
will seem familiar Ralphy drops hands
that he wants a BB gun the father fights
with the furnace the furnace slaps and
my guest
and legitimately good improv overshadows
this prop malfunction let me look at the
bills the bills the bills the bills the
bills would you get that honey please
yeah oh we got our bills my god that was
the only part of the musical that
actually felt genuine it felt real and
not forcibly overblown much like the
original so the only part of a Christmas
story live that actually felt like a
Christmas story was literally by
accident there's a profound Zen riddle
in there somewhere but it's distracted
by another shitty song number this one's
about cross words of course that's what
was missing from the original back to
your favorite quiz show are you a genius
it was the bars on this one it was in
all of the other fantasies why isn't it
in this one are we supposed to assume
this isn't a fantasy and there's
actually a game show going on in his
kitchen yeah about as much as
Broderick's line delivery here isn't the
loudest cry for help this musical
combustor with Rin so it's easy to
pretend everything's fine
production denial never felt so benign
Tinkerbell's Powell forever a boy Peter
the Peter yeah I thought three letters
yeah yeah Peter Piper picked a peck of
pickled peppers Peter Ilya Tchaikovsky
isn't gonna fit yeah he's definitely
gonna win with that encyclopedia
knowledge here's the intro to the
bullies and again listen to the original
narrator thiol
of the book talk about these people as
if they were real compared to a
professional world famous actor who does
this for a living
Farkas what a rotten name staring out at
us with his yellow eyes he had yellow
eyes so help me yellow eyes Scot Farkas
even his name sounded mean and dirty and
Farkas had yellow eyes I swear he did
but to be fair project I paid a lot of
money to do this and the author only did
it because he wanted to we get a song
about how rotten the bullies are and the
more I watch the more I realized the
songs themselves actually aren't that
bad for what they are
they have good melodies and clever
lyrics but they belong in a big
over-the-top production which is now
what Christmas story was ever meant to
be they were little scenes that felt
real because they were little it's like
the brother crying in the kitchen that's
so sweet and feels so real because it's
allowed to be a smaller moment I feel
like here they did that scene they just
be like but they make up for that with
comic gold like the teacher played by
Jane Krakowski being
obsessive-compulsive our first activity
of the day will be well you saw adds
nothing to anything and should have been
left out our apologies if I could get
miss shields to sympathize with my
plight she might phone my mother and
implore her to get me that gun that
doesn't sound cryptic at all
those assholes that owe me that drunk
money will pay nobody messes with
gangster Rafi nobody
he has another fantasy about saving
people with his BB gun again not a bad
number on its own but in the original
it's short and sweet only two minutes in
this version it's six six minutes of
this it's so long boring and pointless
I almost pray there'll be a scrub to
make things more interesting Red Rider
BB gun oh sorry the mics in my fantasy
forgot to turn off we then follow that
fantasy with another fantasy yeah
remember how they were spaced down the
original stupid as now the mother gets a
song about being a mother and boy does
she do a great impersonation of Russell
Crowe from Leamas
the floors have been scribed like a
woman oh wow
[Music]
dance I didn't know you could go through
two puberty's or that your voice could
crack three times well it happens very
[Applause]
[Music]
excuse me for a minute I need to go back
where I was talking about ralfie singing
he's really good and the kids are
alright but he does think better than
Maya Rudolph I'm assuming that'll make
sense later
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like me then you're my clone
and you've escaped and you can't make it
out there on your own come home dunk
number two come on oh you also hate
going to the store to get stamps it's
one of those little inconveniences that
kind of gets annoying but luckily you
don't have to anymore you can just get
them online with stamps comm with stamps
comm you can access all the services of
the post office right from your desk
it's available 24/7 and you can buy and
print real US postage stands for any
letter or any package it's super easy
you just click print and mail well you
might be thinking well I have a package
that's kind of heavy and I don't know
how many stamps to use stamps calm will
send you a digital scale yeah you can
weigh your letters and packages and
print the exact amount of postage every
single time I use it all the time to pay
bills and out cards gifts and send your
cats of Abu Dhabi I think that's like
super illegal but they do it in comic
strips so it must be cute look at it it
looks so relaxing need a vacation it's a
super convenient and easy way to handle
your mail without any hassle and right
now if you use the word nostalgia for
this special offer you receive a four
week trial including postage and a
digital scale so don't wait go to stamps
calm before you do anything else click
on the radio microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in this down that
way you'll get your four week trial
that's dance calm and enter nostalgia
right next to the radio microphone and
I'm legally required to say don't
actually send your kid to Abu Dhabi I
mean I am you sure Chaplin you're going
with it Abu Dhabi you're going to have
it Davi it's gonna be cute
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a letter saying he won a major
award from a contest as you probably
remember they build up this joke the
entire day as to what it could be Dora
just comes immediately after the letter
then what the hell is the point of the
letter all right boys haul it in beats
me
I mean I know what it is I just stopped
caring in this production they say all
the lines you're waiting for them to
recite like math problems being repeated
at school gee Fred G Lee yeah yeah yeah
man once again we get almost no break
going from one song number into another
some major
I will give this due credit he can at
least really sing and dance as well as
perform an impressive quick change in
one show without seeing any of the
people switching him out of the clothes
as you can see this behind-the-scenes
footage of course it does leave an
awkward visual for people at home
reinforcing that the special is in fact
trying to eat you whenever it can and
last of the number is what's the word
I'm looking for heinous
[Music]
[Applause]
need over sixty years ago they actually
ran another live Christmas special it
was an opera called a mall in the Night
Visitors it was about the three wise men
visiting a woman and her disabled child
on their journey and the mother thinks
about stealing the goal to help her
child who has never been shown any love
by the rest of the world here's a clip
of that scene for no particular reason
[Music]
god I hope you feel as dirty as I do
think of a Christmas tree farm owned by
Ken Jeong who and check can be funny but
something like Christmas story live tall
trees short trees green trees pastries
Christmas tree humor
well it's no deep weighing but few
things are thank God
why this is the happiest non moving car
ride I've ever seen
they get a flat from remaining perfectly
still and if you know the original you
know the following scene fits this
special stone like a glove made of
thorns but I didn't say fudge I said the
word because again in the original they
talked like real kids real parents real
situations so it seemed like this really
works in the environment they created
here it's like somebody's saying bitch
and Annie it doesn't match in the
slightest nothing I wouldn't mind seeing
that in Andy but now this is how you do
a convincing scream take
well I think we all know what's up next
Schwartz his mom talking about spelling
test is this because I felt that
spelling test my heart is broken enough
but the words were hard believe and
receive I before E except after C we get
intercepted by another musical what's
going on how was it your fault no sorry
we got interrupted by the original
special we started out with at this
point up for further spelling tests it
was over I was dead but what would it be
the guillotine the hanging the electric
chair drawn and quartered water torture
yeah you really sound concerned
Broderick you talk about different ways
of being killed like you're picking out
nuts
the guillotine the hanging the electric
chair what should I choose the peanuts
the cashews the almonds he says he heard
the word from Schwartz and to Schwartz's
mother's credit played by Anna gusty air
she mimics the original flawlessly you
heard it from your son he heard it from
your son what what they sounded like
actual Christmas story for a minute to
take it away we can't have that in this
musical do the opposite sing a song
about Hanukkah or something
oh come on that was a joke there's
really a song about Monica miss yeah
alright uh hell out of nowhere after a
Ralphie apologizes to Schwartz she
bursts out singing a song about Monica
the hanukkah portion of the show now
look learning about another religious
traditions are fine but hey there's
enough filler in this already be it's
adding to the already torturous running
time and see it's called a Christmas
story if I wanted to Easter Parade and
they spontaneously sang about Kwanzaa
one really crazy night I'm learning so
much more about Hanukkah and this one
song that I have of Christmas in this
entire special goddamn lehayim
hi who the hell are you omma shields
I've got all my Christmas letters to
write I write special messages to every
one of my friends and relatives I'll
teach you how to type sucks look we've
already had this special confiscated by
other specials we really don't need
another one can we please get back to LK
thing not really wanted always this way
no what's that scene in this story it
had nothing to do with the characters I
had nothing to do with the plot oh god
what am i doing just get this over with
as you probably guessed this scene had
to happen at some point
flick gets his tongue stuck on the pole
twice
clasp what is going on
[Music]
you know singing your crime doesn't make
me hear it any less you all have
detention they get him off the pole and
they go on with their day as ralph
fiennes he gets a C+ on his report on
paper skipping the song thank you
Christmas miracles the wait I should see
if there's anything of potential value
[Applause]
so the bullies drop by again and in a
fascinating Lee botched moment I know so
fewer Ralphie just attacks him for
literally no reason in the original the
bully hit him with a snowball breaking
his glasses it hurt he was crying he was
afraid of his father's wrath a father he
loved but he was kind of afraid of and
on top of that he was mocked endlessly
it was perfectly built up so you felt
like you would attack too but here he's
just called names nothing else
the bullies called him names all
throughout the special if anything he
kind of looks insane just randomly
attacking him at this point
more than usual but he breaks them
immediately afterwards and the mother
sings about how things are gonna be okay
well saying is such a strong word
- jumping and they're gone crazy mess a
moment um good job there that was
definitely breathing with words coming
out I could have done that I mean I'm
doing it now but the way you did it I I
definitely couldn't do that from then on
things were different between my mother
and me neither of us ever sung again we
shared a bond next they go to the mall
to visit Santa played by david alan
grier you nailed the spirit of the
original feels here deals from the movie
hurry up the stores closing it's like
the movies looking into a mirror that
can't sing imaginary-friend I got my
limits I think that's what TV Guide
actually said about this special Ralph
gets up there and just like in the
original he's told he'll shoot his eye
out it's just like in living color only
not funny and somehow more offensive the
mother apparently knocks over the lamp
by accident and the father goes to get
the glue pretty similar to the original
except it happens on Christmas Eve
Christmas Eve it just makes everyone
look like an asshole the father looks
like a dick yelling at his wife and
going to the store to get glue and the
mother just leaves the kids behind
because she's so angry these parents are
awful just awful
in the original they were awful but here
their Christmas story - awful special
socks they come home and immediately
make up making this all completely
pointless that sense we know you don't
ever want this to end here's a song
about the kids not being able to sleep
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what the scene needs that yak
from that Ren & Stimpy episode that goes
completely insane Christmas morning
merciful he comes as the last 20 minutes
it's pretty much a line for lying
reenactment replacing all the charm and
joy with a possibly drunk Broderick I
knew that Santa and his reindeer had
already left my old man is one of the
most feared furnace fighters in all of
northern Indiana that I was not only
protect perpetually four years old my
eye my eye is okay if Schwartz the
Schwartz and flick ever saw or at least
what that's what I kept telling myself
how did they never do another Inspector
Gadget with him I know I'm picking on
him too much but a lot of people really
do underestimate the passion of the
original so once again here's the author
a guy who made his living right and
giving acting a shot against a highly
paid Hollywood actor who does this
professionally my eyes are right the BB
must hit my glasses my glasses a few
things brought such Swift and terrible
retribution on a kid as a pair of busted
glasses
well the BB must have hit my glasses my
glasses oh no where were my glasses
nothing brought such Swift and terrible
retribution on a kid as a pair of busted
glasses can you believe the Lion King
invited James Earl Jones back but not me
who weird like the original he pretends
an icicle hit his eye and he gets to
keep the gun the dogs eat the turkey but
forget to take the tablecloth so the
father makes up for that there you go
then they go to the Chinese restaurant
where prepare yourself there's an actual
funny joke here the halls with boughs of
holly
I wasn't expecting that what were you
expecting
I don't know let me time to say I loved
watching this
does this mean we both died it finally
ends with everyone taking a bow but they
never address the most pressing question
that the special raised did the girl
ever learn to type well that's the most
investment I got this special makes me
realize why so many people are hating
Christmas story more and more because
fewer and fewer people know how to
properly represent what made it special
Christmas story has become that kitschy
lamb it's loud ridiculous and people are
increasingly embarrassed by it in the
original it was grounded enough to make
such tackiness but now it's become it
this whole special is like one of
Ralphie's fantasies except they're
supposed to only last a few minutes not
over two hours
I'll give the credit on a technical
level for a live show it is amazing how
smoothly it went and how good it looks I
also say the music for the genre is
surprisingly rather good too it makes me
almost want to check out the Broadway
show but just as a silly musical not as
a good representation of a Christmas
story because I'm believing more and
more nobody can properly capture it it's
a little story in a little town about
little problems but it's done with great
actors great writing and a great
director to go with this overboard with
people who clearly don't understand the
source material or what made it so
special it's a difficult misstep for any
Christmas Story fan to watch nice to
love the original the same way I love
the Grinch despite everyone trying to
destroy that - you simply can't kill a
true classic but with that said this was
an impressive attempt I've met nostalgia
critic and Christmas has just begun
maybe I'll go on
[Music]
[Applause]
my glasses oh no where were my glasses
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out if you've been watching the
news you probably know that Alaska has
suffered a massive earthquake you can
look up footage and pictures and all
sorts of things and it's just gigantic
and it's really really devastating so
this week we're going to be doing the
American Red Cross specifically for
Alaska the address is gonna be down
below you can click on it and you know
American Red Cross they specialize in
going helping people out giving blood
and all sorts of things like that but
this one specifically is for Alaska so
if you click on the link below you can
donate there or if you even want to go
and give blood you know that please do
any donations you make to any good
charity of course is welcome but this
one has great reputation I mean
everybody's heard about it and this one
is specifically for Alaska so if you can
if you have the time or the money or
anything anything you have to give will
be very very helpful so definitely click
on the link below thank you
you